brésil pas de carnaval ni à rio de
janeiro ni à sao paulo prévue à la fin
du mois de février les défilés sont
reportées à avril à cause de la
propagation du variant omikron pour la
première fois cette semaine plus de 200
mille cas de kobe 19 ont été recensés
dans le pays écoutez les précisions
d'augusta lunar dit depuis rio de
janeiro
après l'annulation du carnaval de rue a
dans toutes les villes du pays le très
attendu défilé des écoles de samba de
rio et sao paulo a de nouveau été
décalée la fête devait avoir lieu fin
février a été reporté au mois d'avril la
décision était prise hier soir par les
mères à des deux villes en raison de
l'avancement du variant au micron a dans
le pays mercredi dernier le brésil a
enregistré pour la première fois plus de
200 mille nouveaux cas de covile 19 en
une seule journée et le nombre de décès
est également au secours de dernières 24
heures peu de 350 personnes ont perdu la
vie à cause du virus pour les médecins
et les spécialistes il s'agit d'une
décision raisonnable mais cela reste un
coup dur pour les travailleurs informels
on estime que plus de 25000 brésil hier
dépendent exclusivement du carnaval pour
survivre des milliers des personnes qui
ont déjà souffert les conséquences
économiques l'année dernière lorsque la
plus grande fête monde a été annulé pour
la première fois en 100 ans à cause de
la pandémie de pau v10